C'est évident qui va perdre.
Elle se fait bousculer, se recroqueville, se cache dans un coin.
Souvent, quand il y a un contact initial,
si l'une d'entre elle est trop sur la défensive,
l'autre va lui donner de petits coups, attraper son tentacule pour dire :
« Tu veux m'affronter, tu veux te détourner ?
Tu veux engager un combat contre moi ? »
Elle va l'embêter et fuir, revenir, l'embêter et fuir.
(Cloche)
Règle deux : éviter le contact visuel.
Quand les pieuvres se rapprochent l'une de l'autre pour se battre,
elles ne se font pas face.
Elles s'approchent de côté.
La pieuvre sur la défensive essaye de tourner le dos à son agresseur
jusqu'au moment critique où elle sait qu'elle ne peut plus éviter le combat.
GG : Celle qui attend jusqu'au dernier moment
est la pieuvre sur la défensive.
(Cloche)
Règle trois : fais étinceler tes couleurs.
L'agresseur dans un combat va faire étinceler du noir dans ses tentacules
de façon rapide et vive
juste avant d'initier un combat.
(Cloche)
GG : Oh et déjà --
IC : Nous observons de l'action.
Elles se sont repérées.
GG : Maintenant, elle va venir, elle s'approche, mais pas directement.
IC : Elles sont complètement on ne peut moins parallèles.
GG : Et là --
IC : Elles rentrent en contact et leurs tentacules s'entrechoquent.
(Musique)
GG : Nous avons commencé à comprendre les combats chez les pieuvres.
Vous vous demandez peut-être quelle importance ça a.
Ce genre de questions de recherche fondées sur la curiosité peuvent mener
à des informations et des découvertes inattendues.
Nous en avons appris beaucoup sur nous en étudiant les animaux marins.
Les calamars nous ont appris comment nos neurones communiquent
et les Limulidae nous ont appris comment nos yeux fonctionnent.
Il n'est pas exagéré de dire que certains de ces comportements
observés chez les pieuvres à deux points de Californie sont similaires aux nôtres.